i know you're a massive fan of detective
conan like every time i like see your
instagram stories there's
usually something to do with detective
conan comes out
because like how many times have you
been to the uh the conan cafe and
i try to go there for the third time
this year
and then coronavirus hits okay i got a
refund too
that's good so what was like the
breaking point when you decided okay i
really want to get out of this industry
now i want to retire
because it became a routine like i want
something new in my life you know i want
to feel you
and i also want to change my look every
single day
yeah you know what cosplay is creating i
love manga and anime
yeah like forever like i think maybe in
the future more and more
yeah i want to try different cosplay i
didn't want to loot them too much
i didn't really want when
they started like taking all the
cosplays like you know just that
it keeps the cosplay yeah yeah don't
like put it off like
you do see some cosplays on twitter that
is like it's this cosplay it's like two
pieces of material
like what or it's not even that
sometimes it's like i'm cosplaying zero
two from darling
that's just the weird and then nothing
else i'm like great cosplay
i mean that that's that's on point for
the cosplay because she is naked for
like the first on the first episode
that's literally how a character gets
introduced
yeah because i remember in the uh the
interview that we did when i was uh
talking about like the cosplay stuff i
remember you said something really funny
which is like
you your favorite characters in any show
is usually the characters that have
really small breasts and that
you feel sorry do you feel sad because
you can't call i always go for frats
yeah yeah yeah so i think you were
saying like you cosplayed ram from re
zero
right your favorite character was from
beatrice right yeah
another beatrice fan yes
how do we find the three people on earth
the only three people who like being
joy no no he's he's a normal he's like i
i like red i'm remo
i loved wearing my rem cosplay as well i
love i love wearing female cosplays i
feel like
people figure that out by now i don't
know why it's so freeing you know
like especially skirts skirts you get so
much movement
you know what i mean not that i want to
ever wear maximum efficiency but like
when i'm filming a video and i'm like
clowning around i'm like oh wait hold up
like you can actually like fully stretch
jeans are too constricting i can feel
the breeze on my balls
yeah it's so liberating
the reason i ever interacted with you is
because you posted your hestia cosplay
yeah i was like and you popped it back
you posted your google
[Music]
yeah yeah i'd love to get you on one of
the videos to judge my cosplay sometime
yeah yeah you're getting a professional
cosplayer yeah yeah yeah
you could tell me how bad i am i mean
they just clown on me for like 20
minutes yeah i've i've been on that show
i've been on his like series twice now
and it's uh
man i've never had to like bleach my
eyes like faster didn't you get hives
or actually got hives from one of the
cosplays yeah one of the one of the wigs
you bought
i guess was like really dirty because he
bought it from like a chinese wedding
the cheapest stuff i can find
it's like like a skin rash oh okay okay
it's called something else
like like i put it on in the video just
because i thought it was funny
and then the next day i just had hives
on my neck
and i'm just like coming up to your next
day yeah it was it was just like i was
like oh god what's this
and then i thought about i'm like how
did i get this it's like
a big bed bugs
do you make your own or do you get the
commission sometimes i
i don't make on my own to make one
or sometimes i just order on amazon if
good mo there are a lot of knockoffs
yeah
even on amazon they're all i think we
wrote rerouted through like china
because yeah
it's like amazon japan and then it's
like three to four weeks yeah
this sounds a bit suspicious yeah a lot
of them are just awful because
my arm was like red yeah and i was like
oh yeah that is weird
that was strange i was like please throw
it away yeah
i i'd normally thermos them away if it's
just a small prop and i just
brought her on amazon because it's a
fast delivery so
do you keep all your cosplays uh
sometimes i sell
or i just give away at cons because i
go to animecon i don't want to carry all
the cosplay back to japan
yeah yeah